after Democrats recaptured the House
Majority in 2018 Nancy Pelosi became the
most powerful woman in Washington some
said that she was too old that she the
party needed to trade up for a newer
model but she sure days of age she
remains the only woman to ever hold the
position of Speaker of the House let
alone hold it two separate times she's
now a historic speaker I'm this may be
seen as the Pelosi age in the Democratic
Party she is the glue keeping the whole
Washington scene together that was a few
months back that still holds but a year
ago come on she seemed unstoppable and
the grand dome of a powerful newly
elected group of female lawmakers who
are as mad as hell and weren't gonna
take it anymore
and then they became fed up with it and
then they became congressmen they fight
crime
they are rights wrong they wear white
but they're not all white
the women of Congress Beach Nancy madam
clap back pose
[Music]
she's so woke she can't close her eyes
alright I had that water for that I'm
not all year long she's been a woman on
a very difficult mission resist Trump
without appearing to be unreasonable and
resist the radicals in her own party
without alienating them at the ballot
box if she went too far either way she
could blow her party's chances for 2020
and time after time on issues big and
small the Beltway press and key
Democrats praised her finesse her power
and her style and even her body language
ridiculous partisan investigations we
have just heard that Mexican cities
cooperation compromise and the common
good
and on that infamous clap back we look
at that that's the way you clap when
your husband finally puts the toilet
paper on the roller so condescending but
they poured on the praise heaped on the
praise including on her handling of the
government shut down actor director Rob
Reiner called her a strong brilliant
experienced public servant Joe Biden
clearly agreed at least when Nancy
seemed to have AOC +3 in check she is
masterful I think I heard someone
criticize Nancy or not being liberal
enough come on man
well Pelosi even won plaudits for the
sheer strength of her pointing as in
this now infamous photo during an
October meeting with the president at
the White House her feminist pals and
media boosters went absolutely gaga over
it first can we just do one more beat on
that photo I mean look at that photo of
one woman standing up and you know
giving it to the President of the United
States at a table with all men there
Pelosi on her feet alone you're
absolutely right in that in that room in
the red dress all I could think of was
fences involved in a lot of this murky
stuff too and third in line is the
speaker he's still my heart he's still
my heart did she say she had a red dress
it must have big different color pattern
here in the studio but Nancy's theatrics
don't stop with pointing she walks away
and then she comes back to
I don't hate anybody bracelet
don't mess with me I've never seen any
member of Congress ever leave a room
full of tough Capitol Hill reporters in
stunned silence oh here's the problem by
getting sucked into impeachment though
against her better judgment Nancy Pelosi
also walked away from common sense now
at times over the last few weeks even
the last a month she looked like her
body was actually rejecting impeachment
like a bad organ transplant
I have no message to them we are not
whipping this legislation nor do we ever
with something like this people have to
come to their own conclusions they've
seen the facts that's presented at the
Intel and Intelligence Committee that's
seen the Constitution as they know it
they take an oath to protect and defend
her but they see the constitutional
experts speak about it they'll make
their own decisions I don't say anything
two hours wait a second it's
incontrovertible evidence of an
impeachable offense but they can do it
I'm not going to talk to them about
night with these votes odd and now a
year after accomplishing nothing of
substance except her support this week
after over a year for us MCA Pelosi's
future is suddenly not looking so bright
polls show Louis support ever for
impeaching this president and the swing
state outlook polls horrendous for the
Democrats on that same issue the economy
soaring the market was up 220 points at
the closing bell today
Trump's looking also very confident of
course us MCA is finally done progress
big progress with China his approval
numbers haven't been affected at all by
impeachment his numbers for handling the
economy about 53%
he seems positively AB yulian whether
he's doing events for school choice or
whether he's fighting anti-semitism or
just representing us that's all at
Nadeau meanwhile Nancy's party
they're up on Capitol Hill right now and
they're floundering they're desperately
trying to make people care about
impeachment even though she doesn't care
enough to whip the votes for it but
reality is beginning to sink in if
you're just looking at those independent
voters the polls do not do not look good
for the Democrats
so what struck me about this hearing was
how Donald Trump in a way has already
won Wow
is there a plan B here does San Fran
grandman have a rescue strategy ready to
deploy this is a very sad time for our
country you have to be very prayerful
and that's the angle